foreign
it is delightful to be here um I'm going
to shamelessly shout out the mega
reunion of the classes of 95 96 and 97.
um
because I think there's nothing like
good momentum and then I'm going to
introduce the panel and then we're going
to LEAP right in and I'm going to
acknowledge that I can only see some
things with my glasses on and some with
my glasses off and that'll kind of be a
journey as we go I think
so I'm going to start by introducing
John doer he's an engineer he's a
venture capitalist
he's the chair of Kleiner Perkins and
he's the author of best sellers measure
what matters and speed and scale an
action plan for solving our climate
crisis now
John serves entrepreneurs with Ingenuity
and optimism helping them build bold
teams and disruptive companies as a
pioneer of silicon Valley's clean tech
movement John has invested in zero
emissions Technologies since 2006.
at Stanford he has been a guest speaker
at the schools of engineering business
and law and as Mark mentioned John and
his wife Ann provided the foundational
support for Stanford's first new school
in 70 years
to my left is uh Arun majumdar and he's
the inaugural dean of the Stanford
School of sustainability he also holds
the J precart Provost jail chair
he's a former director of the prep Court
Institute for energy he's the founding
director of the advanced research
projects Agency for energy in the Obama
Administration yes and where he rallied
bipartisan support from Congress and
other stakeholders he is also vice
president of Google where he assembled a
team to create Technologies and
businesses at the intersection of data
Computing and the electricity grid and
finally after a very fine state of the
school thank you John this is Dean
Jonathan Levin he is the Philip K Knight
professor and Dean of rgsb he's widely
recognized for his research in
industrial organization technological
change health insurance allocation of
radius spectrum and economies of
Internet markets John received the 2011
John Bates Clark medal which is among
the most noteworthy prizes in the field
of economics
John was part of the expert group that
designed the first vaccine Advanced
Market commitment and he also helped to
design the fcc's broadcast incentive
auction John serves as well on the
president's Council of advisors on
science and technology
so I'm going to throw our three various
steam panelists some questions toward
the end some of you submitted questions
I'll ask those questions as well
but we are going to begin with John Dorr
because I believe he will set the stage
for us
um theoretically and practically as well
so John you have chosen after a life of
great passion and great accomplishment
to focus full-time on client can you
just start by telling us why this issue
why now well I I got started in this
maybe how many of you remember Al Gore's
movie in Inconvenient Truth
right so my story is I went to see that
with family and friends and afterwards
we returned to our home for a dinner
conversation what did you think
and some of my wonderful Republican
friends said looks like the planet's
warming science isn't so clear that it's
man-made but this could be a problem
when it came to my 15 year old daughter
Mary door
she
she said Dad I'm scared and I'm angry
she said
your generation
excuse me your generation created this
problem you better fix it
in the room went silent I had no idea
what to say what to do
and so I set out with Partners at
Kleiner Perkins to try to find solutions
to The Climate crisis this is back in
2006 and gradually we invested a billion
dollars over three Venture funds and
about 100 or so startups most of which
failed it was very hard but we stuck
with these Ventures there today were our
position anyway worth were three billion
dollars but that that's what got me
started I spoke recently with Mary about
this again and
she said Dad I'm still scared and we
haven't solved this problem what are you
what are you going to do
and I said
I don't think my generation is going to
solve this it's going to take both of
our Generations working together to get
us where we need to go
thank you John
such depth and warmth I appreciate that
very much
you've recently written a book I have
been blessed to read it I suspect many
of you have
um
um oh not not so many not so many that's
excellent I'm really glad you dug into
it it's a good one
um it's called speed and scale it's an
active plan for solving all crime at
crisis but you often say this book is
not a book and there's a plan in it but
the plan is actually a really important
part of the book so I wondered if you
could unpack the book and the plan a
little bit because I think it's so
fundamental to something we all need to
understand better and you profoundly
understand and look at that
you just speak look at a room doing his
part you know when I was making the
decision to back the school and do
diligence on it the one thing I wanted
to know was who was going to be the CEO
who was his Dean and Mark Jesse and
Levine refused to tell me
committed without knowing but I didn't
sign the check until I knew that
you should know that when the school was
announced the formation of it my my
friend who I admire enormously in
climate Bill Gates called up Mark and
said there's one person you want to be
the dean of this school and I'm
surrounded by great Deans right now
we're incredibly fortunate to have a
room
exactly
yeah so it looks like a book but it's
not uh Andy Grove would say it's a plan
an action plan based on objectives and
key results and there's broad agreement
on what we have to do to solve the
climate crisis there's five areas of
major emission
Andy would call these objectives Jim
Collins one of my favorite teachers from
the school would say these are big hairy
ass schools but what makes the plan a
plan
and not a repeat of the same goals that
we know are important are the key
results for every one of these big
objectives like electrifying
Transportation or decarbonizing the grid
there are three to five specific
accountable measurable time-bound
actions that we can track
and we update and we hold ourselves
accountable for achieving these
I think if Andy Grove was alive he'd be
smiling he'd be happy with the
practicality the pragmatism and the
ambition this is by no means a done deal
in fact we are not on track to get these
done right now
but
the advantage and I'm not saying this is
the only plan or even the best plan it's
an engineer's plan the numbers and the
time frames add up we can do this but it
will be a mobilization like how the
Allies mobilize to win World War II it's
going to call on ever the leader inside
of each of you to get this job done
I'm thinking about when you mentioned
Andy Grove and many people in this room
are probably lucky enough to take a
class with Andy Grove while they were at
Stanford which was I think really quite
memorable
um he talked a lot about inflection
points and maybe you've mentioned this
but I wondered if you could dig in more
to why now is an inflection point how
you reflect those ideas in the plan and
then in the book
uh several forces are coming together to
make uh
make this the inflection point
for starters it's over 100 degrees in
California
you know for starters we've had epic
floods
droughts
the a Stanford alumnus Hal Harvey
I'm very taken by his quote he said it's
now cheaper to save the planet than to
ruin it
the cost of solar the cost of wind is
now the cheapest forms of energy on the
planet in most places in the world and
yet there are a whole series of
obstacles it's not just what we do these
six objectives but how we do it in time
the four accelerants how we win the
politician policy how we turn movements
into action how we innovate and how we
invest you know I I took a lot of crap
early in the internet Days by
proclaiming that the internet had been
under hyped it wasn't at all clear that
people could make money selling
applications for a buck on a smartphone
uh but that turned out to be a big deal
I'll say here today
and I'll take the Flack for it the
climate Revolution building a new Global
clean energy economy is the greatest
Economic Opportunity of the 21st century
there'll be thousands of
climate unicorns says Larry Fink and
others the gates break through energy
fund but it's by no means assured that
we'll get this done in time and that's
why we have these accelerants and that's
a key part of the inflection point we
only passed the IRA the biggest climate
legislation in the history of the
country
with one vote to spare
there is not broad Global agreement that
climate is a top two voting issue in the
top 20 emitting regions of the world
that's one of our key results 8.3 in
this program
so
you've got to do more than be personally
virtuous
it's not going to matter that you bought
it like any electric vehicle or put
solar panels on your homes we've got to
move others to Collective immediate and
Urgent action and that's why I'll do
anything to Stanford Business School
asks you have such a reputation such a
track record such potential for
mobilizing leaders that if we do this
with the climate school and we do this
with the business school we'll raise the
bar for all the colleges and
universities around the world and that's
part of what Mark Tessier Levine and
Dina roon want to do at this new school
thank you for that I'm going to ask a
slightly different question
um because probably most of us when we
read the news about climate change it's
it's pretty obvious that there are
communities that are more deeply
affected by climate change than others
and for the people that live in those
communities how do they join the
conversation around change because they
have such a deep investment in it but
sometimes they have less power than
other folks
they have to be organized and mobilized
and called upon there are incumbent
deeply entrenched forces opposed to this
new clean energy economy
[Music]
um
we've got to make this a top two voting
issue we've got to get a majority of
government officials elected or
appointed to support the drive to Net
Zero there are seven specific key
results in the movement of
movements of people turning them into
action it's one thing for Greta
thundberg to be a 16 year old teenager
striking outside the Swedish Parliament
on Fridays that's was what it was in
2018. in 2019 she'd mobilized a million
youth in a hundred cities to turn out
and she raised climate to a top two
voting issue in seven of the 20 emitting
regions of the world mostly nations in
Europe it is not yet a top tuition in
the U.S it's not a top two issue in
China it's not a top two issue in India
we need to mobilize especially with
youth the political support so that the
largest most important climate
legislation in our lives doesn't turn on
one vote in the U.S Senate
we are by no means Home Free we've got
an enormous opportunity
370 billion dollars of climate
investment in the U.S which will have
profound effects around the rest of the
world
but I'm calling on the leader in you
every one of you to join me in this
Manifesto
his plans available for free at
speedandskill.com download it get the
book
and figure out how you in your life and
your family
can make this change
thank you Arun I'm going to start with a
table setting question for you because I
sometimes think it's useful to just know
what you're talking about but first
school at the University in 70 years
tell us about it how is it going to work
there's three pillars of how it works
can you just unpack that so everybody
can start in the same place with what
the school is going to provide an offer
first of all thanks for inviting all of
us to this event congratulations to 25
years the reunion
um
so
if you look back in history Academia has
always adapted to the needs of the time
you're talking about World War II
academic institutions had to adapt yes
we sent our folks down for intelligence
gathering and looking and breaking codes
and you know Bell Labs send people of
the manufacturing plans stop making cars
they made airplanes and tanks Etc so it
would all hands on deck effort but
Academia had to adapt
and if you look at the Cold War
you know there was a lot of innovation
that happened in Academia in response to
what DARPA wanted things to be done
and I think this is the time that we
have to reimagine Academia because what
does Academia value if you think about
it we value going deep into some field
and pushing the frontiers of research
and education in a particular field
climate issue is a wicked problem what
happens in energy affects water what
happens in water affects food what
happens in food affects biodiversity
and what happens in engineering affects
Finance what happens in finance affects
other businesses what happens in
regulation creates new business models
so these are very complex issues which
you cannot neatly break down into simple
things so we have to create an
educational system that actually
explains and gets people students and
others Executives to really think about
how to navigate this and develop the
critical thinking skills
secondly
it is very important that it just we
just heard John talk about the urgency
we have a problem there's a lot of gloom
and doom going around
and as it should be because we're not on
track
but this is where Innovation comes in
this is where Solutions come in and it
is very important for for us to figure
out not only doing the Deep dive in
research but also translate that into
solutions that the world needs today and
the world needs tomorrow
and that needs to happen with level of
urgency and so that is the accelerator
piece of it so the way it is structured
is that we will have departments where
faculty recruited students are recruited
degrees are offered that's a Traditional
School
the two institutes The pre-court
Institute that Mark was talking about
the woods Institute for environment are
coming in these are translational piece
we felt that that is necessary but not
enough I was asked to co-chair the
committee to to figure out what the
structure ought to be so talk across
campus with students faculty alums staff
and you know in Academia not everyone
agrees with everything it's hard to get
100 agreement but there was one thing
that everyone agreed on is that we need
to create an accelerator to accelerate
Solutions and take it to scale as
quickly as possible that was almost
unanimous so now we have an accelerator
and that's a unique entity within the
school with deep connections of course
with the school but also a place where
you can take things to scale and if it
doesn't scale as John was talking about
I can change my personal habits but
that's not going to save the planet
we need to take it to scale and that's
where the accelerator comes in so can
you unpack the accelerator more for
folks to kind of visualize that what are
the ideas who are the people what are
the dollars how does it get out into the
world and and what issues or topics or
Solutions do you hope get through the
accelerator sooner and faster
I'll just give you one example I'm
meeting tomorrow for about two hours
with Folks at Google
this is in the data Commons work
and you know we are as John punter we
are not on track so we have to we have
to think like football we need offense
to mitigate to reduce emissions we need
defense because of adaptation and and
resilience of communities because
they'll get affected right and we need
some special teams negative emissions
and all of that
so tomorrow morning we're meeting about
how to create the data use the data to
create what Johns Hopkins University
created for covid where you could go and
see what's going on
there is nothing like that today
there's a floods going on in Pakistan
this is historic floods
what is the human impact what are people
doing
can we learn something from there that
can be used in floods in Houston
hopefully we won't have but it may
happen heat waves that are going on
elsewhere in the world so connecting the
dots we need to do that now it should
have happened 10 years ago but we need
to do that now and we can't wait for the
United Nations to do it we've got to
just go in and jump in and do it so this
is a global mobilization of
organizations World Meteorological
organizations getting the data creating
the database and projecting so that
people can understand that this is a
Russian Roulette that they're playing
that it may it may happen somewhere else
today we don't have the signs to tell
where it's going to happen next
and it could happen in the neighborhood
and so this is an aspect of scalability
that we could do with data there are
many other examples like that
can you tell us what the experience of a
student might look like coming to and
through the Institute
so we are so glad you asked that
question because we just had a full day
Retreat on what the school should do for
the for the students
and one of the things that we are going
to do is a curriculum that that the
students will be able to take and this
is not just door school students these
are all students at Stanford you should
be able to take and this is if you ask
the question how many students
undergraduates at Stanford take
one course the the first course in
Computing the cs106a
and the answer is shock is 90 percent
yes
yes we want 90 plus percent taking a
course in sustainability on climate
where they are are not neatly curated
with assumptions and they'll be thrown
into the mix
Biden President Biden wants to make the
electricity grid carbon free by one by
2035.
right we just got the infrastructure
bill and the inflation reduction act
that gives you some tools
how are we going to do it
how are we going to navigate technology
what is the state of Technology does the
cost needs to need to come down do we
have the transmission lines out there or
how do we deploy solar how fast can we
deploy solar and wind and do we do we
have the storage solutions to be able to
go so that we have reliability on the
grid those kinds of questions and there
are policy technology Finance business
models all of it markets all have to be
played so we want our students to be
exposed to the reality as opposed to
knife nicely curated and that's the
level of course and one of the really
sort of creative Gentlemens out here in
in The Graduate School of Education
happens to be an Overlord rate in
physics is Carl Wyman yes and Carl is
actually helping us develop this
curriculum and that we're going to
unleash on our students so that's just
to students we are going to do the same
thing for corporate execs for policy
makers we have been talking to people in
Washington and Sacramento
and can we create take this
decision-making classes all the way to
all of them and really mobilize
sort of the population that we need to
if you were to look out and tell us what
that handful of Milestones going forward
are where you'd feel like if we lap this
if we lap this we feel some comfort
we're having success we're digging in
and mattering those are the okrs right
so we're there now the okrs for the
school I mean yes first year we have we
are launching the accelerator it's
really critical to get it right getting
the team right and getting the processes
and the culture the network we cannot
it's sitting here in Palo Alto in
Stanford we don't know what the real
issues are in Louisiana
where the refineries that are going on
there are issues that we need to solve
we don't know the real issues in
Tanzania or India
so we cannot do this alone
so one of the goals is to form a Global
Network of Partners who will not only
educate us and we have to listen to them
but we co-create Solutions with them and
help them Implement those Solutions at
scale so that is part of the accelerator
so the accelerator year one is to get
that going in the right way set it on
the right track and we have projects and
all that are ongoing and hopefully we
can get a few projects launched out like
hopefully the Johns Hopkins for kovid
that's the same thing for adaptation we
can hope we can launch that with the
effort with Partners like Google so
that's that's one we are recruiting
faculty John is helping us recruit
faculty and we have thankfully with the
with the blessing of the gift we will be
recruiting 60 new faculty we can't
recruit all 16 of them in one year but
this will be over six or seven years but
the first tires will set the bar
of set the tone for what kind of people
we're looking at and so that's going to
be very important the depart we have a
new Department we have curricula so all
of that is Year One
thank you that's a good that's a good
place to start year one a lot
um Dean Levin I know you and I have
talked over the years about your beliefs
about really making and you use the
phrase bgs which I think is business
government and society and how to really
help students faculty to engage in that
sort of bgs Arena and so I'm curious if
you can reflect on what you feel like
you've been able to take on in the
sustainability Arena leading up to now
and then how you feel like this will
just Turbo Charge that yeah
um so um thanks Anne-Marie and it's such
a pleasure to have Arun and John here
today thank you both for for coming
um just say one thing about the school
it really is incredibly exciting to have
a new school at Stanford I mean this is
the first new school in 70 years at
Stanford we don't just create new
schools it's a pretty unusual thing
and
um and actually uh just to say one thing
about the creation of the school when
about five years ago the university
recognized our president particular
being and I was recognized that we
needed to do something really
significant at Stanford around climate
and sustainability
and the part of that and that part of
the relationship was that it actually
needed to touch every part of the
University because there were going to
be interesting political science issues
to deal with business it was going to
climate change was going to hit every
area of business it was gonna there was
going to be a need for technological
breakthroughs scientific breakthroughs
it was going to affect health
law everywhere in the university and
there was a committee that Arun alluded
to Arun shared it to ask what is the way
to mobilize Stanford
in a big way around climate and
sustainability and there were two
proposals actually that Arun came back
with you didn't come back the committee
came back with two Alternatives one
alternative was to create a college
which is basically a network across the
existing schools
sort of what MIT did with artificial
intelligence Computing uh a few years
ago
and the other was to create a school and
that came to the executive cabinet to
the Deans the president of the Provost
to debate which way to pursue it
and there was a trade-off in doing that
the the advantage of creating a college
is that it would mobilize everyone in
the university and that would sort of
lift all all boats and and and and get
people focused on on climate
incidentally everywhere at Stanford all
different students and there was to
create a school and the benefit of a
school is
the school's a very special organization
because just as roon described you have
to think about who are The Faculty who
do you want to be hiring and teaching
and what do you want people to be
studying and researching and advancing
knowledge and who are the students and
what are they studying what's the
curriculum and then how do those things
go together it's an ecosystem into
itself and you have to think about it
holistically
and
we went with a school I was a big
advocate for school everyone was in the
end
and when we made that decision and then
president announced two days later we're
going to have a new school which was
amazing
now as soon as we had that discussion
it was apparent that in having a new
school what was the thing that we needed
to take care of outside of the new
school we needed to figure out how to
not lose the beauty of that college
proposal that a runes committee had made
how could we actually mobilize people at
the business school and the law school
and the medical school and Stanford is
unique as an institution to have the
breadth of Excellence across all the
disciplines it is a very unusual place
in that regard and so how could we take
advantage of that in service of this
problem that's really crossed really
truly is an interdisciplinary problem
cuts across every area of human
knowledge and so we got started
immediately after that here we went to
the head of faculty meeting and I said
let's let's just start by what's going
to was on we're on Zoom of course so
let's just start by having some Zoom
discussions we'll meet every couple
weeks and we'll just chat
and it would be great to see faculty
from all the areas come to have the
discussion because sustainable is going
to be a marketing challenge for people
Market it's going to be an operations
question they get into that zero it's
going to be coming up in finance there's
going to be interesting climate Finance
there's we need to just someone's got to
figure out all the accounting for
climate
economics political economy it's a
leadership challenge you know
first being like five faculty showed up
and they you know well sort of a little
like John they sort of said well I'm
kind of interested in climate change but
I that doesn't really touch on what I'm
doing by the end of two years of meeting
or a year of meeting
like about 25 faculty were coming to
these discussions people you know this
is really it I I I've gotten really
interested in climate accounting I think
I might teach a class on it next year
I'm really interested in climate
leadership
I've been thinking a lot about the
political economy of climate agreements
so you know just to John's point about
an inflection point it just is that came
under the radar screen of so many
businesses all around the country it
came out of the Russian by the way the
students were there 10 years ago yeah
that's right
so they were like hey what took you so
long to get going but
um we you know we now we got there and
it's been a great partnership with Rudin
with with Cam Buller who was the interim
Dean before him and and Arun is just off
to an unbelievable start uh with the new
schools on fire it's really exciting to
see and when the school starts this year
I mentioned in the last session well if
70 students who are joint degree MBA
Masters at the door school will have uh
I think six faculty who were GSB faculty
took a joint appointment
uh in the door school going to help with
recruiting and teaching and building the
faculty of the school will have uh we're
going to introduce an Executive
Education Program uh over the course
this year working together with the
faculty from the door school we'll have
a new sustainability entrepreneurship
program which like a roon said that'll
be open to students from across the
university so GSB students
or school students but then everyone
else as well
some of my favorite things that have
happened in the last couple of years
among our students related to climate
sustainability
are
things that got started when our
students MBA students connected with
either students or faculty from around
the University
so I'll just give you one example of
this just to I hope will be many more in
the next couple of years one of we had a
student who was graduating the MBA
program in 21
and he had a background he worked at
Tesla as an engineer
and he came here and he wanted to do
something in batteries
and before the pandemic started he wrote
an email to one of the material science
faculty over in the engineering school
he said I'm really interested in
batteries you know I read some of your
papers can we come talk this as a fellow
who's using who does his his lab is all
about using AI to optimize battery
design
they got to know each other a little bit
and they went to lunch one day and they
said well let's start a company
and they started the company when when
our student graduated and the day after
graduation I went for a walk with him
and we were walking around the Stanford
campus and um and he said uh he said I
when I was asking him about he said he
said this clean energy Revolution this
is just to John's Place this is going to
be the this is going to be the the
digital the next digital Revolution this
is going to be huge and I'm going to be
at the Forefront of it I'm going to
build a giant successful company he's
got a great pitch by the way you could
see he raised a lot of money and you
couldn't see why and uh and and he said
um
he says to me as we're walking around
past the quad he says you know
25 years I'm going to come back for my
25th year reunion so this place is going
to be different he said now everybody
thinks that this is Silicon Valley
he said this is going to be the future
of the clean energy because I'd asked
him why did you start your company here
is this the right place and he said in
25 years ago from Irene we're going to
go for a walk
and we're going to look around and he
said this is going to be all the great
clean energy companies are going to be
located right here and I'm going to have
started one of them so
you know that's a great who knows if his
company's going anywhere it's a venture
back company you know like John said
some are going to work out some of them
aren't but
you know that's the kind of thing that I
hope we're going to get going over the
next couple of years with this new
school it's going to be an amazing
opportunity for our students and for
Stanford to really do something
meaningful
actually this guy's so good in
fundraising he raised money from me
I don't know much money but I put my own
money in dude you know your pitch is
good when two people are talking about
your pitch and they know who you're
talking about
um and he told me he can you can retire
with this with your investment
it's not working out for you
um Dean Levin I have another question
for you as you scan this group of faces
and um and the armies of other folk who
have left the GSB I think a llama really
eager to know how they can engage and I
think it's and I mean this respectfully
to Mark it's easier to engage if you're
an energy guy but what if you're just a
super capable leader and manager and
knower of much content how do those
folks come and say I I want to be part
of this yeah so I'll actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna say something at the risk of
um uh uh putting one of my faculty
members under a deluge of emails but
um our faculty member at the GSB who's
been leading our business and
sustainability efforts as a fellow named
Bill Barnett he's taken a joint position
also at the door school and
um you could email them
laughs
and well he's not gonna be able to do
this forever but he he actually he's
been amazing one of the things when he
started doing this about he and I
started those discussions about two
years ago here at the school about what
we're going to do understandability and
he's been just an amazing leader in
getting our efforts going and I think
really helpful in the design of the of
the school as well and um one thing she
said at the beginning was you know we
don't know who of our alums are
interested who are either working on
climate issues or sustainab issues or
just have an interest in getting
involved we don't have a list of that
and I need to compile one and he so if
you want you can look him up Bill
Barnett and should have been done say
hey I'm interested and we'll find we
will you know I don't know what's
something for you to do right away but
we would love to just know that you're
interested and excited and want to be
involved in that way that'll give us a
chance to to engage you over time
please John I'll suggest three things
you can do
and these are actions these are part of
the action plan first of all get your
organization to commit to Net Zero by
2050 to make and meet those commitments
second of all
uh you're a parent maybe or you're part
of a public school district get your
school district to adopt electric buses
there's funding for it the climate
payoff is is phenomenal
and the third thing that you can do is
vote
demand that
at every level of government we have
pro-climate
pro-neuclean economy leadership
three things there's a really excellent
three things and those are so much about
re-reminding ourselves of why being
civically engaged people matter so much
thank you for that I'm going to turn
over to some questions people sourced up
and the first one is for you Arun and I
I suspect you answer this question all
the time but there's been a lot of
discussion about corporate funding for
the school particularly dollars from
folks who are fossil fuel
or earners how do you think about that
in your own strategic planning
yeah this has been a topic of much
interest I would say
um look I think the school per se is not
going to take funding from fossil fuel
companies for its operations it's
research funding that comes and
um for sponsored research projects uh
there is a academic freedom issue
faculty can work with anyone as long as
they can comply with the rules and
regulations of the dean of research so
that's there the issue comes in when you
have initiatives that are like what's
called affiliate funding Etc
and I think that this is a so let's let
me back up I think we all know where we
want to be
we want to be fossil free there's no
question about it because the emissions
we have to pay for the the Penance of
emitting in the past is the negative
emissions thing we have to do that
the question is the pathway and who do
we engage with along the journey right
and
um I wrote a letter to the whole
Community saying that we should not be
working these are my own values we
should not be working with companies
that deny climate change undermine the
science of climate change
misrepresent our partnership with then
them and block and tackle uh policies in
climate change and you know and they say
something climate commitment but they're
doing something else right that's we
should absolutely not work with but I
also said that painting the whole
industry with one brush you know may not
be wise and I think there are some
companies that are trying to move in the
right direction and they have made
commitments they're trying to keep their
commitments and
um and so I think we should if we can if
we see that they're doing the right
things at some point we have to say that
they have the scale that is needed to
address this issue we operate at the
laboratory scale out here so we need
partners and at some point we have to
say this is all hands on deck and so
that's been my position but I've also
said that look this is my position today
I'm not fixated on this
I would like to listen to what others
have to say
and I've gone around listening to
students student groups during summer
and a lot of students are not here right
now so in the fall I'm really eagerly
waiting for the students to come back so
I can have these conversations to find
out what are people saying and we are
going to then collect all that people
have said without any attribution and
say this is what people are actually
saying right now and then to see how to
then figure out how to actually mobilize
the campus so it's actually a really
iterative process I'm sorry it's a
really iterative yes it's an iterative
process that's right but I think we all
have to be sure where we want to be we
want to be fossil free and as the
question is the journey
um
I'm going to defer to any of you on this
question and I want to ask it soon
enough so if there's things we want to
thick it out we can do that
um but are there other pieces and each
of you have highlighted pieces so maybe
you've gotten most of this in the mix
but are there aspects of climate change
are there aspects of the school that
haven't come to the fore if people leave
the room not knowing those things they
won't be as Rich for it
I think the issue I strongly feel having
grown up where I grew up in India
environmental justice is an
international issue
and I think we need to pay attention to
this
this is unbelievable Global transition
that we're going to face you talked
about World War II this is
world war three correctly the transition
that we're going to have we can't leave
people behind at the end of the day this
is about Humanity
and I think it's going to be very
important that we look at at this
globally we are Stanford is a global you
know platform and we have to understand
that and so that's something in my
senior associate Dean and Leadership we
have someone looking at International
Partnerships we have someone looking at
environmental justice and to make sure
diversity accurately so this is
something that we are very so we're
trying to create the culture in the
school to make sure that it is inclusive
as we go through this transition we have
to go do the mitigation negative
emissions and the the football analogy I
can repeat that again but that's we have
to do that yes but it's at the end of
the day we cannot because we are we
could be in an echo chamber in the local
community and think that we're solving
the problem where the issues could be
quite different and complex elsewhere
and we've got to listen thank you for
that I'd like to take your invitation to
Echo something on this this very topic
we would not have passed the IRA without
the steadfast support in Activision
activism of the green advocacy groups
and they knew and they said as long as
there's 300 billion dollars
in the ira
they will back and they will support
this so building a durable political
consensus
goes beyond social justice it's
political pragmatism in terms of getting
this job done there's a quote in the
best quote in this book comes from a
graduate of the business school Maureen
Paul jobs and she says
the closing quote the climate crisis
should be looked on as one of the
greatest opportunities
greatest opportunities that has ever
been presented to humankind
to deal with education Equity Health
Equity
in economic equity
and I'll note for folks who don't know
that John and I are both mutually quite
fond of Laureen we have different
relationships with her but we are both
quite fond of her and we both really
admire her focus on climate too her I
think she committed 3.6 billion dollars
yes
focused on climate Up Until Now
philanthropy and climate has been two
percent of U.S philanthropy two percent
it needs to be 20 or more
can I just underscore one thing that
John said
people are really happy about the
inflation reduction Act and the
infrastructure bill
and they should be
but this is a very small slice of what
needs to happen these are only the
carrots
if you look at the infrastructure the
inflation reduction act for hydrogeneral
these are only the carrots you cannot
change the economy with only carrots
there needs to be sticks
we need a price in carbon we need clean
energy standards because we will not get
economy-wide deployment of solutions
without the sticks and carrots the
carrots are great to create you know
reduce the green premium or green create
green opportunities
Etc but at the end of the day if you
want economy-wide change you have to
have carrots and sticks and for that the
political mobilization that is needed to
get the sticks in place will be even
harder than what it was to get the
carrots carrots are easy and I I really
think it is important to think a
mobilization of the population to think
that this isn't their interest to do
that no matter where they are in the
United States
thank you for that
um
maybe another question I'll ask and this
is actually kind of a more pedagogical
question but I kind of appreciated when
people searched up questions they didn't
entirely know what we'd be talked about
today so they were bringing up different
ideas
but it was a question around how you
pedagogically train and teach around
thinking about the trade-offs involved
in creating sustainable opportunities
and so the example this person used in
the question they sent in was it's so
clear that moving to electric vehicles
is important but there's also this piece
around and it's a social social it's a
political there's lots of mining that
then takes place and it's not just about
the communities where it happens but
it's also about the cost of doing that
mining to get you to a new EV future so
how will you think about that when
you're supporting students and being
leaders in this Arena
so I look at it it's not an either or
I think we often fall in the Trap of if
you do this this might happen so we
can't do this right and then you're in
paralysis
so we have to go towards clean energy
economy whether it's battery materials
and mining for that and we have to do
the mining in a environmentally
responsible way
whatever we do at that scale
could have environmental impact right
likely to have
and the question we have to ask is
you know the trade-offs as you pointed
out how do we mitigate the environmental
impact as much as we can
and still move mobilize towards the
issue of climate change so I think we
have to do both and if we ignore one
that's gonna the unintended consequences
of that will be devastating because we
are now living in the unintendent
consequences of the 20th century we
never thought well people had raised it
they ignored right so we have to look at
the as part of our effort with its
research education and or deployment or
Solutions we gotta look at the
unintended consequence of what we do and
mitigate as much as possible
I was one thing I would add to that is I
I think the places where the in terms of
carbon reduction the places where the
trade-offs are the most Salient are not
in the United States and they're not in
the developed world they're in the
developing World it I mean the U.S
carbon emissions peaked in 1995 in the
United States and they're down 40 off
peak in the UK and throughout a lot of
Europe they're they're down and
um we haven't borne that much economic
cost for leveling off carbon or even for
reducing it in in Europe technology has
it has advanced to make it as John
already said cheaper to do in many cases
renewable energy production and so the
big trade-offs and the hard problems a
lot of them are in the developing world
where the trade-offs are
you know there's something incredible
about illumination we take it for
granted but you need to have lights on
to be able to educate kids and let them
learn to read and that means you need
more power and more electricity in India
throughout Africa in parts of China and
so the really hard problems a lot of
them are about how do you get better
Technologies out to those countries and
and and ways of of alleviating those
trade-offs so they're not facing us
incredibly Stark trade-off between
warming up the planet and having the
lights on for the people who live there
and you want to move out of poverty and
that's a hard trade-off and I I think
that's one where the
places like Stanford can make a real
difference actually because partly that
how do you address that how do you
alleviate that trip partly it's about
having great technology and great
science and great ideas
hopefully we're going to generate some
of those we already have some of those
and how do you
then take ideas Technologies like that
and actually get them to scale in
low-cost ways
and that's a that's a huge huge
challenge for the world and and one
where that's the kind of thing where I
hope Stanford could really make a big
difference in the next decade
thank you I'm going to ask one more
question I'm going to ask each of you to
feel that if you want
um I mean I guess the observation I
would make is that many people in this
room have a married door
they've got some young person in their
life
quite honestly I was talking to an angry
an angry person this morning although
she was really more having trouble with
Dropout at college so we've discussed
climate but not today
um
but I guess I'm wondering if each if you
could leave us with something where when
you've looked that way you've thought
this gives me some optimism or hope it
could be a student it could be a project
it could be an organization but
something where on this path that we
know is going to be rough that we know
needs to get a lot more sticks on it
that it doesn't have right now and those
sticks are going to really catch a lot
of us
um what what's something that each of
you really feels hopeful and optimistic
about
I'll start
um a very good friend of mine
also happens to be a GSB Alum and the
longest serving board member on Tesla
this guy called Ira Aaron priest
that class of 96. that's nice of 96. Ira
is ours
we take a roll call and say he's not
here I'll let him know that he's not
here unless he's here in the audience
his he called me one day and he said
that my daughter is in high school
and she has created this climate boot
camp for high school students would you
be willing to speak to them I said sign
me up
and she's now going to I just saw her
she's going to college right now and
she's going to get this to the college
level
and really mobilize the youth and that
gives me a lot of Hope because the next
generation and this is one individual if
you look at Google searches on
sustainable products
that is going up exponentially not just
the United States worldwide there's data
out there so I think there is the youth
the Next Generation as John pointed out
it's not just our generation but ours in
the next so that we can save our
grandkids and the great grandkids I
think that's what is giving me a lot of
Hope about the next so I'm really
looking forward to undergraduates coming
here and and listening to them and
helping them
thank you two things give me great hope
one was a conversation after an
interview about this book or plan with a
reporter from The Business Insider who
turned off her tape recorder and said
John I want you to know that what I've
been doing with my daughter at home
every night is reading together a page
or two from the book and we talk about
it
and I never imagined when writing this
engineering plan that it would have that
audience and that awesome impact
but it brings me to remember something
that I heard first from Arun which is
the proverb is that we inherit the Earth
from our ancestors
it's not quite right
what's really going on is we're
borrowing it from our children
and that's
something that gives me great hope
I'm pretty hopeful about what these
folks are doing
I just it's great to have the school and
have a chance gift
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you John thank you Arun this is a
really really wonderful way to launch
into a weekend together we're deeply
appreciative thank you and Marie thank
you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]